من ساعه ما استولت حركه طالبان على الحكم
ليفغانستان قراراتهم المشحفه بحق
الافغانيين عموما والنساء خصوصا ما بتخلص
وبعد ما كانوا منعوا الافغانيات من الظهور
على التلفزيون بدون نقاب الى جانب تخصيص
فصول دراسيه ومداخل بتفصل ما بين الجنسين
فالجرات الحركات صدمه كبيره من ايام بقرار
جديد بيقول انه ممنوع التعليم الجامعي
للافغانيات القرار طبعا لقى تمديد دوله
كبير واستهجان من المنظمات الحقوقيه ومن
المجتمع الدولي حتى انه فنانين افغان ايضا
عبروا عن رفضهم للقرار لكن على طريقتهم
الخاصه الفنان الافغاني حسن رضى يختار
صوره رمزيه لكن بالحقيقه جدا معبره
اعتراضا على هذا القرار الفنان استخدم
رساله وزاره التعليم العالي للضمنت قرار
منع الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي كغطاء
لجسد امراه مثل كانه كفن لها وزير التعليم
العالي حركه طالبان محمد نادين كان امس
اكدوا قال بمعنى انه لو ضربوا الحركه
بقنبله ذريه ما راح يتراجعوا عن قرار منع
التعليم الجامعي للنساء للاسف
الموضوع يا جماعه ما توقف هون بس ولكن
حركه طالبان ايضا مستمره بقراراتها واصدرت
مش من زمان طبعا اوامر لا المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان تمنعها فيها من
تشغيل النساء وبررت قرارها انه الموظفات
ما عملهم بيلتزموا بقواعد اللباس المناسبه
وهدت بتعليق تراخيص المنظمات لو ما نفذت
القرار